hé excusez-moi, nous avons tous oublié nos pièces d'identité,
voudriez-vous faire voler six Packers, puis
quelqu'un l'a fait pour moi quand j'avais votre
âge, c'est comme un rite de passage
ouais oh
mamelons sur le ciel pourquoi voudriez-vous modifier
les mamelons
c'est Bouddha vous êtes-vous converti à
Bouddhisme J'attendais de faire ça non
non whoa sors juste une seconde à droite
Je dois rester tranquille pendant une semaine à Monda
cappuccinos nous célébrons
oh regarde si mignon tu devrais acheter oh hé
whoa tu es censé frapper je  je ne
te connais pas c'est une nouvelle amie tu pourrais faire
semblant d'être ma mère
mrs.  la chasseuse Annika ne prend pas de mesures
pour son avenir, c'est une sorte de
travail intéressant à avoir,
quel type de licence faut-il pour que
vous veniez au bal et je ne peux pas
simplement flotter pour savoir quel lundi vous
appartenez là-bas avec nous
vous avez manqué  Savannah a son bébé et
tu es la marraine qui diable est-
ce
donc tu es trafiquant de drogue hé as-tu
entendu celui de la femme adulte qui a
commencé à traîner avec un groupe d'entre vous les
meilleurs enfants non quoi non je n'avais jamais entendu  de
celui-ci avant que
papa oh bon sang dépasse ma [ __ ] d'accord
c'est mon père oh bon
tu désosses mr.  klaxon non ce n'est pas comme
une croix